okay so I am not religious in fact I
don't really even like the word
spiritual what I am though is addicted
to reveries and I'm interested in
notions of transcendence right when you
put things together in a certain way and
they exceed their materials right when
2+2 somehow equals 5
these are transcendent effects when
things exquisitely work together to
render an experience that seems beyond
measure almost with a supernatural
charge and I think that these
experiences usually require the proper
and reverential management of attention
an ability to steer awareness right
the 1965 hippie phrase of dismissal get
out of my movie reflects this heightened
stewardship of internal life and when we
have or when we acquire the capacity to
steward the contents of consciousness we
become masters of what we pay attention
to and there's a great line about
attention that reflects this reverential
quality that it in douses the world with
it says absolute unmixed attention is a
form of Prayer now again I'm not
religious and I am NOT spiritual but I
can vouch for the fact that when you
attend to things fully when the doors of
perception are cleansed everything
appears to man as it is infinite is
Aldous Huxley famously said the
psychologist William James famously said
your experience is what you attend to
the psychedelic philosopher Terence
Mckenna echoed the same things when he
said you become what you behold to
behold is to hold in mind to behold this
to lend your attention to behold
is to model what you're looking at
within your own consciousness to let it
take over the cognitive machinery to
become what it is that you are beholding
this is the secret of again experiences
that feel reverential Tran
sended Mehta mythical Mehta mystical
right again I'm not religious and I'm
not spiritual but I believe that our
perceptual machinery can come together
with certain experiences that we can
stage design settings that emulate
Godhead whether or not you believe in a
divinity that exists outside or in spite
of us there is such a thing as
experiences of the divine that can be
rendered within our minds if we learn to
control our attention stewardship of
internal life ultimately means taking
control of your movie this is the key to
any and all lasting satisfaction to
invest in immersive experiences that
catapult you into trance that hijack
your awareness so that you enter what
Janet Marie calls a state of liminality
that fuses cognition and dream the space
of poetry the space of reverie right
again absolute unmixed attention as a
form of prayer and when you design these
kinds of experiences and when you allow
your awareness to be hijacked you enter
a kind of platonic realm you enter a
space beyond self and beyond time you
become what you behold why am I telling
you all this because like you I'm
interested in figuring out how to spend
my time while I heat while I'm here and
while I exist
and the perhaps the greatest lesson the
the greatest passport to this space of
mind to this place of being is
stewardship of internal life so get out
there and take control of your world by
taking control of yourself
you